hey this is presh talwalkar
in this sentence the number of
occurrences of the digit 0 is blank
of the digit 1 is blank
of the digit 2 is blank of the digit 3
is blank of the digit 4 is blank of the
digit 5 is blank of the digit 6 is blank
of the digit 7 is blank of the digit 8
is blank and
of the digit 9 is blank
the challenge is to fill in the blanks
with numerical digits
so that the sentence is true
i'll give you hint there are two
solutions
can you figure them out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so we can solve this problem by guessing
we know that each digit occurs at least
once
so let's just try saying that each digit
occurs one time
we'll do this for all the digits except
the digit one
now let's count out the number of
occurrences of the digit one
we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
so we can guess that the digit one
occurs ten
times but we now have a problem with
this sentence
the number 10
involves the digit 1.
so we now have a total of 11 occurrences
of the digit 1.
so let's replace this value of 10
with the value of 11.
now when we do that we have another
problem we've introduced another digit 1
so now we have a total of 12 occurrences
of the digit 1.
so let's replace this value with 12.
when we do that we actually introduce
another digit 2.
so we actually now have two occurrences
of the digit two
so let's replace the value for two to be
occurring two times
when we do that we've removed one of the
occurrences of the digit one so the
digit one now appears exactly 11 times
and when we do that
it turns out we've stumbled across a
solution
everything in this sentence works out
and this sentence is true
this is a solution to the puzzle
so the digit one occurs 11 times the
digit two occurs two times and every
other digit occurs one time
so we've come across one solution
how do we find another
we'll just make an educated guess
the digit 1 occurs 11 times and that's a
two digit number
let's try and see if we can get we can
avoid double digit numbers and let's
suppose it just appears nine times
so we'll replace the value of 11 with
nine
so where does this guess take us
well the first thing is that now the
digit nine occurs two times
so we're going to say the digit nine
occurs two times and will replace that
value
we now have the digit two
occurring three times in this sentence
so let's say that the digit two
should have a value of three
when we do that we now have the digit
three occurring two times
so let's replace this line with the
value of two
this brings us back to our three
occurrences of the digit two
so everything looks good except for one
problem if you count out the number of
occurrences of the digit one we now have
only seven occurrences
because we've replaced a couple of
occurrences of the digit one with the
values of three and two
so we'll replace
the value of nine to be seven
and now we have two occurrences of the
digit seven and this replaces the two
occurrences of the digit nine
so we can swap the values for the lines
of seven and nine
and when we do that
we actually stumble across another
solution
everything in this sentence is accurate
there are seven occurrences of the digit
one
the digit two occurs three times the
digit three occurs two times and the
digit seven occurs two times and
everything else occurs one time
so in summary we have two different
solutions
this is one solution of the puzzle
and this is another solution
did you figure out the answer
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description